thousands of seriously ill coronavirus
patients
have now been released from u.s
hospitals all carry permanent scars
but only seven in the u.s were saved
by a rare double lung transplant the
procedure is complex and is only
performed on people with terminal
irreversible damage after the virus
ravaged their lungs
cbs news chief medical correspondent dr
john lepuk spoke exclusively
with one of these survivors
in mid-march the early days of the
pandemic in the u.s
coronavirus was not on brian cunes's
mind
i started just a very little about it
sure enough so the next day i heard
about
next it days because i got hit with it
the 62 year old was working at his
suburban chicago auto shop
when he hit a wall i just got back from
lunch and i got sick
boom i was done he would shake so bad
like a jackhammer that was like a shiver
but i mean a
violently jerking shake cune's wife
nancy rushed him to the hospital i don't
remember anything for like
a month and a half after that the first
time i woke up in the hospital
i couldn't breathe his lungs were
severely damaged and unable to supply
enough oxygen to his body
even with a ventilator so doctors
started ecmo
a life support treatment that uses a
machine outside the body to add oxygen
to blood
he was on it for a hundred days i could
feel it my lung wasn't working
it's not moving i breathe alone in the
hospital
he prepared his wife daughters and
grandchildren for the worst
i said don't expect me to come home my
lungs are done
i ain't coming home this is it yeah
love you goodbye and then finally
what happened they said there's nothing
else we can do
it's either get a transplant or die like
took a chance
and those guys were relentless they
wouldn't give up
those guys were dr ankit bharat and his
transplant team at northwestern medicine
this was the treatment of last resort
for him we told him like i cannot
you know say with certainty that he will
get through this but we have done it
once before
just a month earlier dr bharat's team
performed the first successful double
lung transplant on a covet patient in
the u.s
she was 28 years old now it was kunz's
turn
when you opened up his chest in the
operating room what did his lungs look
like
in patients who had this covalent 19
lung injury and lung failure they
developed these punched out holes
throughout the lungs and brian he had
big time big cavities
the lung was stuck to the heart to the
diaphragm to the test wall
the day after the 10 hour surgery
doctors took brian off the ventilator to
test out his new lungs
and of course the first thing i do is go
wow
because i could breathe again what was
that like
it was something that was good you could
feel air moving in
yeah i'm moving out is that okay
okay getting tired cunes has weeks of
rehabilitation before he can go home
he's lost weight and muscle tone but
gained a new appreciation for the
miracle of a simple breath of air
because like for a couple days i i was
breathing
non-stop 24 7
like that so when it's doing itself
you don't even know it that's great i
suspect you will never
take breathing for granted again
i won't dr bharat says this rare
treatment may be expanded to help a
relatively
small number of other severely ill
covert 19 patients
meanwhile after working for years as a
self-employed mechanic
cuets has now retired and told me i got
a little camper
maybe i'll go see the usa
[Laughter]
wow john what a story and those doctors
are miracle workers thank you very much